[Music]
foreign
news briefing it's Friday June 2nd I'm
Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
today we're going to talk about
generative artificial intelligence which
can do a lot but when it comes to
writing software code some Chief
Information officers say it could be
doing too much our Enterprise technology
reporter Isabel busquet joins us to
discuss why AI generated code is a
potential problem for cios and their
companies
[Music]
but first a chat Bond named Tessa has
been taken offline after the program
which was designed to help people
suffering from disordered eating started
giving weight loss advice the national
Eating Disorders Association which
operates Tessa said it was looking into
what happened of course this all comes
at a moment when eating disorders are on
the rise weight loss drugs are
disrupting the diet industry and chat
Bots along with full-fledged AI
assistance are starting to change the
way we get health care and information
for more on this we're joined Now by wsj
family and Tech columnist Julie jargen
so Julie to start with can you give us a
little background on this chat bot when
was it launched and who created it the
chat bot named Tessa was originally
designed by researchers at several
universities including Washington
University School of Medicine and
Stanford University School of Medicine
and the design this chat bot to try to
fill a gap in care that exists when it
comes to eating disorders there are few
doctors and a lot of people who need
this kind of help and they were trying
to develop something that would be
preventative
so they designed this chatbot that would
help through conversation guide people
to reframe their own thoughts about body
image in an effort to try to reduce the
development of Eating Disorders they did
a clinical trial on it it showed good
results and then the national
Eating Disorders Association decided to
adopt this chat bot for use on its
website in February 2022. how do the
problems with it first come to light the
problems first came to light over the
Memorial Day Weekend there had been some
news in the past week about the national
Eating Disorders Association
shutting down its helpline which is an
information line staffed by humans and
there were news reports about that that
got people interested in learning more
about Tessa which is not according to
Nita supposed to be a replacement for
the helpline but
people knew about the chat bot and
decided to test it out so there were
some eating disorder Advocates who asked
some questions about weight loss and
received some answers answers that you
wouldn't expect from the national Eating
Disorders association with advice on how
to lose weight and weigh yourself every
day that seems like pretty shocking
advice for people who are reaching out
to the National Eating Disorders
association yes it is and I spoke with
the CEO of Nita and she said that type
of advice clearly violates Nita's
policies and that's why the organization
took the chat bot down let's just get
something straight though because Tessa
it isn't supposed to be a generative AI
chat bot I mean we've seen mistakes
so-called hallucinations from other
generative AI chat Bots but that's not
what Tessa is right well that's not what
it was designed to be the university
researchers who developed Tessa worked
on it for a few years it was incapable
of providing unscripted answers there
were a set of answers that were
developed to respond to any type of
question that might come without the
ability to go off the rails they don't
know yet what happened a new company
took over the administration of the chat
bot it's named Cass and their CEO told
me that the company uses AI to
understand what users are typing and
that some of its other chat Bots that it
has developed have generative AI but he
didn't answer the question I asked him
about whether this Tessa chatbot had
generative features they say that
they're investigating what went wrong
and so what happens next so Tessa is
going to remain down until this
investigation is complete the CEO of
Nita said it won't go back up until they
can ensure that it's a closed system
that can't generate responses outside of
the strict guard rails that initially
had been put in place alright that's our
family and Tech columnist Julie jargon
generative artificial intelligence can
do a lot create a picture compose an
email and write computer code already a
lot of Fortune 100 companies are using
AI to generate code from Johnson Johnson
to United Airlines and Goldman Sachs but
some it executives are worried about all
of those new lines of software and not
necessarily for the reasons you may
think with me to discuss that is our
reporter Isabel busquet Isabel so just
at a very high level what kind of code
can AI write essentially if you think
about a software programmer's job
they're just sitting there typing away
and these generative AI coding tools
GitHub co-pilot is the big one right now
essentially just work to suggest
portions of code and if you think about
the way chat GPT works by suggesting the
next logical words in a sequence they
sort sort of function similarly to just
suggest the next type of logical chunks
they're not writing entire applications
but they can be really helpful in
helping developers get from point A to
point B a little bit faster right like
you said that sounds helpful so why are
it professionals raising some concerns
yeah I think it's it's interesting
because it's super helpful if you're a
software developer but if you're a CIO
or the I.T chief of a big organization
suddenly you're dealing with a situation
in which your developers have the
ability to be writing a ton more code
than they ever were before and also with
these tools there's the idea that if you
are not an expert software developer you
could also you know throw your hat into
the ring start writing new code new
applications start creating new software
and so the amount of software that can
be created
it could go up exponentially and that's
a concern for cios because they're the
ones that have to manage that software
they have to ensure it's all up to date
they have to keep it organized for the
people who haven't written code or
haven't done much software development
before that are now using these programs
what are they dealing with or what are
the things that they're going to need to
keep in mind according to the cios that
you spoke with one interesting thing
here is that the skill set for
developers is going to look very
different than it has in the past and so
while in the past you might have been
creating something out of nothing now
you're very much functioning as someone
who's going to be doing more and more
checking over work so in that sense like
this skill set is really changing there
have been things called Low code and no
code tools that have been around for a
while and the whole idea behind those
was that they would democratize software
development and and that people who were
not developers would suddenly be writing
tons of code and there are sort of
varying perspectives about the extent to
which that's come to fruition and so I
think in some ways these kinds of tools
are continuing progression of that
narrative and for the cios who are
saying there's just going to be too much
we don't know how to deal with it what
steps are they taking to deal with this
yeah I think the most important thing
they can do is just make sure they have
the right guard rails in place and they
just have the right sort of controls and
checks around any software that's
completed or put out that they're just
doing enough work to ensure that it's
not shoddy poor code that's gonna
immediately need to be updated as soon
as it comes out and you know also just
ensure that there's a purpose for every
piece of code that's being built alright
that was our Enterprise Tech reporter
Isabel busquet
and that's it for Tech news briefing
this week tnb's producer is Julie Chang
our supervising producer is Melanie Roy
and our executive producer is Chris
sinsley I'm your host Zoe Thomas thanks
for listening and have a great weekend
[Music]
foreign